[Musique]
Michel seoget Christian Dufour bonsoir
bonsoir On attendait le rapport rouleau
avec impatience est-ce qu'il allait
donner la bénédiction au gouvernement
Trudeau pour avoir utilisé une loi
d'exception donc pour donner plus de
pouvoir entre autres policiers à l'état
confisqué des banques des comptes de
banque pouvoir saisir plus facilement
des véhicules etc le juge dit oui
prenons ce premier élément là par contre
on va parler des critiques mais sur
cette première question le juge donne
raison à Justin Trudeau Michel C
il lui donne raison mais il dit aussi on
aurait jamais dû se rendre là alors il
dit au moment où le gouvernement a
décidé d'évoquer la loi sur des majeurs
d'urgence la situation était
suffisamment dégradée que ok ça rejoint
le test qu'il faut pour
avoir recours à cette
mais il dit avant ça il y a une série de
développement qui se sont passés qui ont
à peu près tous viré-croche
[Musique]
des forces policières surtout la police
d'Ottawa qui est sévèrement blindé
là-dedans et à la d'autres qui ont fait
que un moment donné la situation s'est
dégradée on n'avait pas les
renseignements qu'il fallait du côté
policier on avait de mauvais
renseignements quand classique c'est la
police d'Ottawa qui pensait qu'il
resterait pas pour la fin de semaine
alors qu'il y avait déjà loué toutes les
chambres d'hôtel alors
il y a une grosse critique de l'appareil
policier ok mais je vais je vais revenir
parce qu'effectivement vous avez raison
ce qui dit en deux mots c'est on
n'aurait pas dû se rendre là si les gens
avaient travaillé ensemble mais mais
rendu là Christian Dufour rendu devant
cette crise il donne raison au
gouvernement en disant oui ça aurait pu
dégénérer oui aurait pu avoir d'autres
blocages oui il y avait donc
urgence nationale et que le gouvernement
était justifié d'utiliser une mesure
vraiment très exceptionnelle
pousse un soupir dessus soulagement
parce que de blanc en fait sur sa
décision d'évoquer la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgences parce qu'un protège
potentiel de menace dangereuse mais ça
rapporte qui est intéressant parce que
l'Union assez ils disent à contre-cœur
que je dis ça parce que insiste quand
même sur le sur le niveau politique
la police municipale de Power ça va de
soi du gouvernement de l'Ontario aussi
on s'en souvient de ce fort de politique
glorieux là-dedans mais aussi critique
que l'approche politique du gouvernement
Trudeau à l'égard de la pandémie où il a
acheté de l'huile sur le feu c'est qu'au
début de ce mouvement là il faut s'en
souvenir
il y avait un appui assez important des
Canadiens au mouvement c'est le premier
ras-le-bol qui venait de la base à
l'égard de l'état sanitaire les gens
étaient beaucoup de bonnes foi horsel au
départ en fait monsieur Trudeau a
démonisé ces gens-là et acheter de
l'huile sur le feu même monsieur Trudeau
aujourd'hui a fait un espèce de meilleur
couple
j'aurais pas exactement la même chose
donc rapport intéressant dans ce sens là
c'est que ok où on était rendu on
n'avait pas d'autre choix mais si on
s'est rendu là c'est entre autres parce
que Justin Trudeau dans la gestion de la
utiliser la pandémie en fait à des fins
politiques pas très très admirable je
trouve ça intéressant en fait du rapport
c'est qu'au départ moi je le rappelle ça
a dégénéré ce mouvement à la très très
nettement mais au départ la majorité des
gens étaient pas des complots de
complotistes il y avait un état d'esprit
de la population canadienne que
quelqu'un
la preuve c'est qu'il y a eu des
réactions du gouvernement logo du
gouvernement Trudeau à l'égard de ça
donc c'est un rapport intéressant donc
Michel C on va je vais vous donner la
parole mais avant on va entendre on va
entendre monsieur Trudeau on va entendre
monsieur Trudeau qui dit j'aurais pas dû
utiliser moi je vous entends plus
j'entends plus personne est-ce que vous
m'entendez tout le monde oui tout le
monde alors toujours continuer à parler
tout va très bien on va attendre
monsieur Trudeau qui dit
j'ai utilisé des mots très durs j'ai
peut-être effectivement il dit pas ça
mais c'est ce que ça veut dire jeter de
l'huile sur le feu on écoute
je ne retire pas mes propos mais je
regrette que mes propos sur ces gens-là
ont pu être des pecs comme une attaque
sur les gens en général ou les gens qui
qui voulaient exercer leur liberté de
parole et d'expression c'était pas mon
intention et j'aurais pu
choisir mes mots différemment
alors voilà Michel et Christian il
reconnaît qui en a mis un peu que ça
faisait enfin c'est pas ça mais on
comprenait puis à l'époque ça faisait un
peu l'affaire des libéraux que de jouer
là-dessus de diviser les conservateurs
également
un peu ça fait beaucoup la faire des
numéros il y avait comme un il y avait
commencé soyons clairs à l'élection
précédente souvenez-vous de l'article
depuis
viser les noms vaccinés on va se servir
de ça comme façon de diviser les
Canadiens après on va gagner à cause de
ça et c'est pas mal la stratégie qu'ils
ont pris dans la dernière campagne
électorale c'est pas juste que Monsieur
Trudeau a dit et oui c'est acheter de
l'huile sur le feu pendant le début de
confort des camions
partenaire
c'était une stratégie électorale de
l'année
Christian
le rapport dit aussi que le c'est
l'échec du fédéralisme je cite le juge
dans la mesure où Monsieur Ford était
aux abonnés à ça la police de tawa ne
parlait pas assez à l'autre
gercer à la police municipale à la
Police provinciale de l'Ontario que les
gens n'ont pas travaillé les mains dans
la main
fédéralisme les paliers de gouvernement
municipaux c'est l'échec des relations
intervenantales parce que en fédéralisme
les municipalités c'est pas un ordre du
gouvernement je m'excuse
tout à l'heure mais elle va dire
donc c'est clair que la coordination que
les nouveaux niveaux de gouvernement n'a
pas bien fonctionné c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire si c'était plus parlé si
vous avez au moins travailler en silo
comme on dit parfois on serait pas
arrivé à ça donc ça ça a vraiment
contribué à la crise dans le sentier de
toute façon on ne sentir le backwom on a
sentiments
des corps policiers mais en même temps
je trouve qu'un critique quand même
assez dur de Monsieur Trudeau
j'aime un peu alimenté cette crise mais
une poussée quand même un énorme soupir
de soulagement parce que sur le plan
historique c'est venu un blanc formel
pour l'invocation de la loi des mesures
d'urgence ça serait à son dossier comme
sans lui reproche constant ce mouvement
là c'était juste
je vais revenir puis on reviendra sur la
l'esprit général mais sur ces critiques
ou les gens n'ont pas travaillé ensemble
le juge le souligne il rappelle presque
Ottawa cette année là
la personne qui est blindée
comme oublier quand ta voix faisait
partie de sa province et qui a Police
provinciale de l'Ontario a été très à la
marge dans ce dans toute cette affaire
là il y a pas été très présent
sur les lieux à Ottawa alors que la
police d'Ottawa n'avait pris un bras qui
avait besoin de renfort pour télécharger
des renforts un peu partout y compris
des gens de la SQ etc alors ça c'est
clair mais du côté de Monsieur Trudeau
c'est le meilleur rapport qui pouvait
espérer je veux dire même s'il est de
l'armée un peu même si le juge a des
réserves il reste que pour lui sentir et
pour ça sera pas obligé comme disait que
c'est à son dossier oui parce que c'est
dans une démocratie je vous donne la
parole dans une seconde dans une
démocratie Christian et Michel utilisé
cette loi-là c'est cette lourd de
conséquences durant l'avait jamais
utilisé celle-là la nouvelle mouture et
si le juge avait dit
rapport secret qui font état donc de
tentatives chinoise pour déstabiliser
l'élection on avait déjà parlé de la
2019 on parle à 2021 je vous fais
écouter monsieur Trudeau qui dit oui
c'est vrai qu'ils ont essayé les chinois
mais ils ont pas réussi on écoute
ça fait des années qu'on est conscient
de ça au Canada et dans le monde et
c'est pour ça que nos agences de
sécurité et de renseignements
travaillent de façon acharnée pour
contrer cette influence de façon
régulière et particulièrement par
rapport aux élections pour les élections
de 2019 et 2021
l'ingérence par Beijing et le
gouvernement
est inacceptable et nous devons prendre
les actions concrètes pour l'empêcher et
pour protéger le souveraineté de notre
pays et c'est le grand bon sens il faut
ramener le gros bon sens chez nous
ce poids lièvre qui dit il y a 8
j'aurais 8 députés de plus nutrité
dit-il de cette implication chinoise on
le saura jamais mais là ça ne s'arrêtera
pas là Michel cette histoire-là
non parce que la Chine est vraiment en
train de Sayer de dans plusieurs pays
comme ça
d'être fier assez la politique interne
de du pays et c'est pas juste par les
élections bien sûr par les élections la
communauté chinoise on a appris il y a
pas longtemps qu'il y avait des postes
de police clandestins qui surveillait
les gens de la communauté chinoise au
Canada les institutions dans les
universités qui ont été vus comme
finalement des lieux d'espionnage et
tentatives influence alors c'est
commentaire des Chinois contre ce qui se
passe au Canada
puis on est vraiment pas le seul pays
qui vit ça alors il faut être
extrêmement vigilant parce
qu'effectivement
c'est quelque chose de très sérieux
et j'ai trouvé autant monsieur Trudeau
était capable de se défendre de cabine
dans le façon dans le dossier de la
commission rouleau autant en ce qui est
à l'implication de la chaîne qui était
pas du tout crédible en fait c'est très
grand en fait ce qu'on vient d'apprendre
on sonne frustration au sein des
services de renseignement si un coulage
à l'essai de certaines informations qui
laissent entendre qu'il y a certains
députés entre autres qu'on le veut
britanniques conservateurs qui ont pu
être battus à cause de ça on va aussi
les limites du merveilleux
multiculturaliste parce qu'on veut
l'utilisation des associations de
communauté ethniques entre chinoise pour
miner la démocratie canadienne et aussi
il y a des questions qui se posent
comment ça se fait qu'au Canada ne pas
encore enregistre des agents étrangers
il y a une espèce de manque de fermeté
du Canada face à une chaîne qui est
puissante qui est extrêmement agressive
là-dessus monsieur Trudeau après midi
mais j'ai trouvé que c'était juste la
langue de bois il n'y a un peu
l'évidence ces groupes j'espère qu'il va
avoir une enquête là dessus qu'on va
pousser ça parce que c'est c'est pas
rien ce qui est arrivé et moi on peut
pas le prouver mais c'est clair que les
personnes chinoises favoriser les
libéraux de façon minoritaire parce
qu'on veut du trouble donc on se dit
qu'on s'est minoritaire c'est plus
facile à manipuler c'est un compte et
conservateurs entre autres les députés
de chiots là chinois conservateur encore
le bruit britannique on peut penser
qu'il a été battu entre autres à cause
de ça la preuve très bien on va reparler
évidemment pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI